huit mois après s'être placée à l'abri
de ses créanciers l'entreprise louis
garneau renaît la firme d'investissement
montréalaise corporation financière
champlain devient partenaire de
l'entreprise qui recevra aussi un prêt
d'investissement québec et une marge de
crédit de la banque nationale louis
garneau quitte la direction de
l'entreprise mais reste l'actionnaire
majoritaire et président du conseil
d'administration
la production manufacturière se fera
désormais du mexique
alors qu environ 70 employés vont
travailler au siège social de saint
augustin de desmaures en banlieue de
québec avec nous ce soir louis garneau
bonsoir monsieur garneau bonsoir
monsieur fillion comment vous sentez
vous ce soir soulagé ouf je me sens
comme après une grosse course de vélo
qui a duré trop longtemps à ça a été
extrêmement extrêmement difficile mais
j'ai fait les jeux olympiques ça j'ai
trouvé ce soit facile par rapport à ce
que 1 un entrepreneur fait endurer
parce que le problème c'est la durée
c'est c'est le stress mental c'est la
pression sur la famille sur les employés
sur l'équipe mais je m'en sors grandi
sortir de jack comme une meilleure
personne meilleur président du conseil
est tantôt vous avez dit j'avais l'air
d'être un gars la retraite monsieur
fillion et qui était proche mais on va
être une trilogie à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise et je vais je vais être
chef de la création à l'origine un très
gros travail à faire à l'interné pour
vraiment sortir des produits innovants
comme je le faisais dans le bon vieux
temps
et jésus que cette partie création elle
est très importante pour pour vous pour
tout entrepreneur d'ailleurs est ce que
est ce que vous avez cru un certain
moment que c'était terminé
absolument écoutez je pourrais pas vous
dire le nombre de nuits blanches que
j'ai passé j'ai imaginé les pires
scénarios il fallait que je sois au
bureau j'ai frôlé la dépression écouter
ça a été ça a été l'enfer pour moi et à
l'époque je ne savais pas comment m'y
prendre parce qu'on a toujours été une
compagnie que fait de l'argent n'a
jamais perdu d'argent sont
cinq ans et les deux dernières années
ont été mauvaises mauvaises créances du
groupe à l'international et après ça la
tempête parfaite multitude d'événements
qui arrivent des gens qui s'en vont au
marché qui se resserre la banque qui te
met la pression et devenir un avis
d'intention de venir sur les comptes
spéciaux avec le banquier c'est plus la
même relation qu'on aimerait dans le bon
temps parce qu'on avait une compagnie
qui était parfaite et la transformation
se fait quand même un certain prix
humain quand même parce que votre votre
production sera délocalisée transféré
aux mecs et il y aura beaucoup moins
d'emplois combien d'emplois ont été
perdus au québec et à saint-augustin
environ la moitié
vous savez on a tenu à bout de droit le
système manufacturier québécois et dans
mon domaine j'étais le dernier carré ma
sortir de la production locale
tout le monde était dans des pays où la
main d'oeuvre est beaucoup moins cher
donc j'ai maintenu une production locale
et une production mexicaine une
production asiatique et ça nous a mis
aussi dans le trouble carrément de
vouloir maintenir ces deux grandes
plateformes de production et m'a
expliqué attendus de la fin j'ai attendu
de perdre de l'argent puis que le
banquier me tire les oreilles pour
arriver à prendre les décisions parce
que je veux que j'avais peut-être là car
trop sensible envers mes employés envers
toute l'équipe et aujourd'hui je vous
dirais que cette fracture qui a eu dans
l'entreprise depuis huit mois a permis
de créer la nouvelle entreprise qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui le holding
lg 5.0 et qui est une compagnie qui va
être plus flexible qui vont être plus
plus agiles ou si en plus du talent et
qui en même temps se voir se retourne
vers l'innovation et la création de
valeur pour conquérir le marché mondial
mon objectif n'avait pas été atteint
j'ai des ambitions de plusieurs
centaines de millions de dollars de
ventes
on est un brin de marque extrêmement
connu dans l'industrie du vélo ont fait
des produits de classe mondiale et
souvent comme québécois ont
ignore ce qu on est et on l'a vu aussi
avec tous nos distributeurs qui avait
très peur qu'on tombe
est ce que est ce que le complexe de la
coved et l'on reparle quand possiblement
d'une nouvelle fermeture des magasins au
québec ne s'est pas fait là mais c est
sur la table est ce que ça pourrait
fragiliser de nouveau votre entreprise
écoutez ça a été dur avant qu'à vide ça
a été dur à l'arrivée du kobus mais on
s'est rendu compte que le vélo était un
bien essentiel
beaucoup de gens se servent de la
bicyclette pour le transport pour
remplacer le transport en commun
je vous annonce aussi dans cyclingnews
la semaine passée aux états unis
on annonce en 2030 des ventes qui vont
doubler par rapport à l'automobile
alors le parc automobile est en train
saturer les vélos c'est ça que c'est
fait on a le vent de face
ça fait trois ans le vent vient de
tourner puis dieu merci coûté j'en ai
des frissons quand je vous en parle
parce que c'est un moment donné on
voyait pas qu'est ce qui allait arriver
même l'industrie du vélo dorel shimano
avait des problèmes de deux ans et
d'autres industries était vraiment
problème alors qu'aujourd'hui on a une
pénurie devait nous pénurie de raquette
et c'est une mauvaise et une bonne
nouvelle mais on va être obligé de
[ __ ] est très très fort pour servir
les clients et servait aux québécois qui
ont été tellement fidèle depuis notre
cas on vous sent soulagé mais ce gars
normal
oui ce soir jouvin petit champagne avec
mon épouse on pense à vous avez raison
ça lui plaisait